it's a historic first looking to the
Future
and worthy of space
so 85 of the rockets by mass that's
sitting on the pad right now is 3D
printed that's what no the rocket prior
to this with the highest percentages
probably I don't know maybe four percent
3D printed by mass so it's a huge step
change and you know as as such we need
to prove that a 3D printed rocket can
survive the environments of a Rocket's
flight the company says it's 3D version
is cheaper and quicker to produce than
conventional Rockets
33 and a half meters long and nearly two
and a half meters wide the rocket has
arrived at the launch pad in Florida's
Cape Canaveral
the mission has been named good luck
have fun and essentially will test
whether the 3D printed rocket can reach
and survive orbit a global first so far
everything's looking great the the team
has you know has gone through the major
reviews that they need to as we as we
head into launch the uh the weather
outlook is looking quite positive
if successful it could in future provide
a launch vehicle for commercial
satellites the much-anticipated liftoff
will take place on Wednesday at 1800 GMT
that's 1 pm Florida time potentially
marking a new era in 3D printing and
space travel
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera
well let's get more on this joining us
live from Melbourne Florida's Donald
Platt an associate professor of Space
Systems at the Florida Institute of
Technology very good to have you with us
on Al Jazeera so space economy right now
seems to be all about how much how fast
how cheaply a company can deliver useful
things to orbit which of those three is
best served by 3D printing
well I think that fast is definitely
something that a 3D printing printed
system can provide it can do a very
flexible new design of a rocket that can
put all sorts of payloads into orbit
and do so relatively quickly as well
it's uh it's a great game changer really
to launch so many satellites that people
are interested in putting into space now
literally thousands um per year really
in the in the coming years yeah and we
are seeing more and more satellites
going into space the payload uh right
now would carry these satellites into
space but it doesn't compare to what
SpaceX what a SpaceX rocket can take
into space though does it can you see
um it improving in that regard
sure this is a Pathfinder this is the
very first rocket that's 3D printed that
is going to be able to even reach orbit
so we have to start fairly small and
move up from there
but demonstrating the technology is
really a critical First Step as we move
forward to larger rockets that are 3D
printed in the future
and what next after that do you do you
think you know 3D printing of space
equipment is that something that could
possibly be done in space is that part
of the vision do you think
absolutely that's a really exciting
element of 3D printing and more
generally what is called additive
manufacturing where you take a raw
material and you kind of spin it into a
final product
imagine going to Mars for instance and
using Martian soil to create your
habitat or or a rocket system that can
get you back from Mars and not have to
take everything with you and to be able
to sort of live off the land I think
that's a great future step for uh this
type of technology that is one of the
the aims of Relativity space isn't it
absolutely and in fact that's why they
have chosen the rocket propellants that
they have because you can make those
rocket propellants with the atmosphere
of Mars so this is a very important
first step in that area of what's called
in-situ manufacturing or basically
living off the land as I say this is a a
tremendous game changer and no doubt you
will be watching that launch very
closely thank you for your time on this
that is Donald Platt joining us live
from Melbourne Florida thank you
thank you